on your device there live lots of little
spies yes the very same cookies that you
are constantly feeding to websites
cookies with the idea of Lou montulli
for internet shops so that the site
could find out about how often its
customers were visiting the page it was
at this point that the internet stopped
being anonymous there have been efforts
to legally regulate cookies for example
the eu's cookie law but nonetheless your
safety lies in your hands look here we
visited several random sites and a
number of them offered us straight away
to look at the cookie settings if you're
concerned about the safety of your
personal data then don't ignore this
button of course that's if it's there at
all on a few sites they didn't even give
us the option
you can set up a cookie Blocker in your
browser
or install a special extension that will
block cookies but some sites won't allow
you to use them if you don't accept
cookies
don't fill up your computer with cookies
clear your browser history
stay alert take care of your data